[Musik]
nichts nutzt ein Auto so schnell ab wie
das neue Auto des Nachbarn lautet eine
alte Weisheit aus der Automobilindustrie
ein Zitat aus einer Zeit in der ein
sozialer stand mit materiellem Wohlstand
gleichgesetzt wurde die vertriebslogik
der Automobilbranche war klar definiert
Aufstieg bedeutete vor allem mehr Gehalt
und somit auch meist den Luxus eines
eigenen Autos welches im besten Falle
auch durch seine Größe und seinen Preis
beeindruckte
Verbrauch oder Nachhaltigkeit in der
Produktion spielten eher eine
untergeordnete wenn nicht sogar
überhaupt keine Rolle
erst in Zeiten des Stillstands zeigt
sich die wahre Bedeutung der Mobilität
ihre Alternativen ihre Perspektiven und
Bewertungen das hat die corona-krise
mehr als deutlich gemacht mehr denn je
steht der Mobilität nun ein Wandel in
unserer Gesellschaft bevor dabei steht
das neue mobilitätsparadigma das dem
Auto zunehmend seine Bedeutung als
status-objekt nimmt an erster Stelle
[Musik]
Lebensqualität und individuelles
Wohlergehen drängen in den Vordergrund
die sinkenden ökonomischen Möglichkeiten
des Einzelnen das steigende
Umweltbewusstsein und die grundsätzliche
Frage nach den wirklich wichtigen Werten
im Leben toppedieren bisherige
vertriebslogiken dieser Wertewandel
schlägt in der Gesellschaft inzwischen
auch auf die Fahrzeugindustrie durch in
den USA besitzen inzwischen etwa 30% der
19-Jährigen keinen Führerschein mehr in
vielen 2007 noch mehr als 17% der
Neuwagenkäufer auf die Zielgruppe der 18
bis 34-Jährigen so waren es laut
Marktforschung letztes Jahr nur noch 11%
das Ende des Autos auszurufen wäre nicht
nur verfrüht sondern vor allem verfehlt
wir werden ganz sicher auch weiterhin
auf Individualverkehr setzen denn die
Werte Mobilität und Freiheit besetzen
dauerhaft einen wichtigen Stellenwert
für Menschen doch der Zugang verschiebt
sich der Zugang zu Mobilität wird
günstiger ressourcenschonender und
letztlich auch bequemer
Prestige drückt sich nicht mehr in
Hubraum aus und immer seltener im
eigentlichen Besitz gerade in der
Generation why wird sichtbar es geht
nicht unbedingt darum ein Auto zu
besitzen sondern vielmehr um den Zugang
dazu
nicht umsonst blühen neue
nutzungsmodelle auf
Carsharing zeigt einen möglichen Weg in
die Zukunft mehr als 40.000 Fahrzeuge
stehen in München Berlin Köln Wien
London Amsterdam aber auch in vielen
Städten der USA und Kanada zur Verfügung
der Markt für kurzfrist mietmodelle ist
gerade dabei sich zu definieren
viele carsharing-firmen setzen bisher
auf einen Mix aus postfossilen Dieseln
und Verbrennungsmotoren doch immer mehr
Länder Städte und Regionen verkünden das
Ende von Diesel und beziehenmotoren und
Leuten so die Ära der E-Mobility ein
aber E-Mobility heißt dabei nicht nur
emissionsfrei sie wird damit auch zum
vorherrschenden Antrieb in der
mobilitätswelt die Batterie wird die
Basis vor allem für PKW und leichte
Transporter darstellen
wasserstoffbasierte Antriebe werden für
schwere Transporter und LKW eingesetzt
Norwegen plant es für 2025 Kalifornien
und Großbritannien für 2035 das Ende
verbrennungsmotorischer Antriebe auch
China der größte Automobilmarkt der Welt
will ab 2035 nur noch umweltfreundliche
Fahrzeuge zulassen
vor allem die USA sehen sich als
autonation Nummer eins mit dem Wandel am
Automobil konfrontiert
einen Blick in die Zukunft des
amerikanischen Automobils
der Wettlauf um die Zukunft des
Automobils hat begonnen vor mehr als
einem Jahrhundert leisteten die USA
Pionierarbeit bei der Massenproduktion
von Autos wir sind weit über das
model-tee hinausgewachsen und das Model
X von Tesla hat im Rennen um die
Elektroautos die Führung übernommen
Amerikanerinnen sind eher zögerlich beim
Umstieg auf E-Fahrzeuge wie man anhand
der Werbung sehen kann aber diese
Werbung wirft einige ernsthafte Fragen
zum Wandel in den USA auf lassen Sie uns
mit dem Klimaexperten axadrati einige
dieser Fragen klären die Frage wo stehen
die USA eigentlich wenn es um ihr
Fahrzeuge geht offensichtlich liegen wir
weit in der Norwegen zurück
ja Norwegen ist meilenweit voraus in
Norwegen besitzen etwa 90 von 1000
Leuten Elektro oder plug-in-hybridautos
in den USA sind das etwa fünf von 1000
und es gibt andere Länder mittleren
Bereich wie etwa Schweden und die
Niederlande die etwas über der USA
liegen es gibt also noch viel Luft nach
oben
ist auch ein Land in dem fossile
Brennstoffe und Gas gefördert werden
vielleicht gibt es E-Fahrzeuge auf den
Straßen aber es gibt immer noch eine
Menge Tanker auf den Meeren und vor der
Küste bedeutet der schnelle Umstieg auf
E-Fahrzeuge denn auch weniger Verbrauch
was sie da Brennstoffe
definitiv werden wir einen Rückgang des
Ölverbrauchs in Norwegen sehen denn 50
bis 70 Prozent der Autoverkäufe sind
jetzt bereits Elektroautos aber wir
dürfen auch nicht vergessen dass die
derzeitige Fahrzeug Mehrheit
größtenteils benzinbetrieben ist und es
etwa noch 15 Jahre brauchen wird diese
zu ersetzen sollte der Verkauf alle
Benzinautos heute eingestellt werden
der Rückgang des Ölverbrauchs ist also
überschaubar und liegt in Norwegen im
Moment zwischen 10 und 15 Prozent
wenn man sich die steigenden Käufe von
Elektroautos ansieht bekommt man den
Eindruck dass die Leute wahrscheinlich
eher optimistischer sind was das
Aufladen dieser Fahrzeuge angeht denn
das ist ein großes Problem auf dem Markt
für Elektroautos
gewissen Preis kauft man ein E-Auto wenn
man nicht rechtzeitig von A nach B kommt
weil man zwischendurch anhalten muss und
lange Ladezeiten hat inwieweit ist das
Aufladen noch ein Problem
wir haben bereits seit etwa zehn Jahren
Elektroautos und es werden immer mehr
anfangs gab es die Sorge um Reichweite
wie weit komme ich mit einer vollen
Batterieladung
die Batterien waren teuer und die
meisten Autos hatten keine große
Reichweite heute besitzen diese
Batterien die nötige Kapazität und
Reichweite allein das Aufladen stellt
noch ein Problem dar
dabei dürfen wir nicht vergessen dass
benzintankstellen seit 100 Jahren auf
der ganzen Welt gebaut werden das Netz
zum Aufladen von Elektroautos ist sehr
sehr jung wenn Länder also ihre
ambitionierten Verkaufsziele für
Elektroautos erreichen wollen müssen Sie
den Ausbau eines ladenetzes unterstützen
in den USA hat Tesla hervorragende
Arbeit beim Aufbau seines ladenetzes
geleistet aber auch andere
Autohersteller müssen aufholen oder mit
Adaptern versuchen einen Teil des Stroms
aus dem tesla-ladenetz zu übernehmen
dass sich an der e-revolution beteiligen
will während Tesla einen großen
Vorsprung zu Konkurrenz hat beginnen die
alten Autohersteller wie fort und VW
aufzuholen viele beginnen nun die
Elektrifizierung ihrer Flotte
voranzutreiben Blumberg hat hier einmal
genauer hingeschaut
das Streben nach einer Wiederholung des
Tesla Erfolgs hält den e-hype am Leben
Teslas Börsenwert ist auf über 700
Milliarden Dollar gestiegen mehr als 7
der nächstgrößten Autohersteller
zusammen das Unternehmen ist jetzt eine
Kategorie für sich und trotz selbst Elon
muskwarnungen dass ein Aktienkurs zu
hoch sei was zum großen Teil dem
Phänomen Tesla zu verdanken ist es ist
ein allgemeiner Konsens entstanden dass
den Elektrofahrzeugen die Zukunft gehört
doch sowohl für Start-ups als auch für
traditionelle Autofirmen birgt dieser
Wandel gefahren es bleiben zwei große
Fragen erstens kann ein anderes Start-up
den Erfolg von Tesla sinnvoll
wiederholen und zweitens wird der Markt
für Elektrofahrzeuge schnell genug
gewachsen um sowohl die etablierten als
auch die Newcomer zu unterstützen
Nicolas dramatische Aufstieg und Fall in
nur wenigen Monaten war das große
abschreckende Beispiel des letzten
Jahres das Unternehmen hatte sich
vorgenommen die Lkw-Branche zu verändern
indem es die Dieselmotoren großer
Lastkraftwagen durch Batterien und
Brennstoffzellen ersetzt die Aktie
feierte ihr Debüt und stieg in den
Sommermonaten in die Höhe doch im
September brach sie ein schaut Zeller
behaupteten Nicola habe die AnlegerInnen
über seine Technologie getäuscht während
die Aufsichtsbehörden Untersuchungen
einleiteten und das Unternehmen jegliche
Anschuldigungen bestritt wechselte der
Firmengründer zu einem konventionellen
Automobilhersteller
Unternehmen wie GM und Daimler bekamen
Anerkennung dafür dass sie ihr Geschäft
in großem Umfang umgestaltet haben auch
wenn sie dies erst spät umsetzen während
die Welt noch auf den Verbrennungsmotor
setzte hatte Daimler die Vision bis zum
Ende des Jahrzehnts mehr als die Hälfte
seiner weltweiten Verkäufe zu
elektrifizieren aber mask hat große
Ambitionen Deutschland und den Rest von
Europa zu dominieren in den USA haben GM
und Ford elektrische Pickups in Arbeit
in diesem Segment haben sie
jahrzehntelang dominiert müssen sich
aber noch in diesem Jahr mit dem Tesla
cybertruck auseinandersetzen
mask hat sich an die Spitze gesetzt kein
anderer Autos die EU lobte ihn so sehr
wie Volkswagen CEO Herbert dies als er
den vw-ausgabenplan für das nächste
halbe Jahrzehnt bekannt gab der Name
Tesla fiel sehr häufig dies sieht Tesla
als einen der wichtigsten Konkurrenten
und eine Referenz für VW er sagt maskabe
den nötigen Software Background und
Fähigkeiten die andere erst noch
erarbeiten müssen einige Analyst in den
sagen voraus dass VW und Tesla in
absehbarer Zukunft ein globales ividuol
bilden werden
aber die wohl viel wichtigere Frage ist
hat Herbert dies verstanden wohin sich
die Branche entwickelt
[Musik]
nEO ist der jüngste Hersteller von
Elektrofahrzeugen der sich dem am
schnellsten wachsende ivy-unternehmen in
China den Beinamen Tesla Killer
eingefangen hat der Name ist berechtigt
denn china ist der größte Markt der Welt
doch noch vor zwei Jahren war Neo fast
bankrott hier erfahren Sie wie CEO
William Lee das Ruder herumreißen konnte
und nun versucht es mit Elon Musk
aufzunehmen
in der Welt der Elektroautos gibt es
einen großen Namen
und dann kommen alle anderen einer der
größten Kunden von Tesla ist jetzt China
das Landwirt gerade zum am schnellsten
wachsenden Markt von Elektrofahrzeugen
oder Evis der Welt
china ist ein riesiger sich schnell
ändernder Markt bis 2021 sollen etwa 30
oder 40% der Verkäufer von Tesla aus
China kommen aber es ist ein Fehler zu
denken das Tesla das einzige Unternehmen
ist dass ich hier auf dem Vormarsch
befindet infolge der sprunghaft
gestiegenden Nachfrage gibt es in China
inzwischen über 600 IV Unternehmen die
mit Tesla konkurrieren wollen
nEO ist eines der intelligentesten
iv-unternehmen Chinas im Laufe des
Jahres 2020 ist der Aktienkurs von nio
um etwa 1000% gestiegen AnlegerInnen
sprechen bereits vom chinesischen Tesla
oder auch vom Tesla Killer
Neo hat viele Namen aber im Wesentlichen
ist es eines der vielversprechendsten
und bekanntesten Unternehmen für
Elektrofahrzeuge aus China
noch vor zwei Jahren war das Unternehmen
fast bankrott dies ist die Geschichte
wie Neo den droh und in Bankrott
abwenden konnte und zu einem der
angesagtesten Unternehmen der Welt wurde
das Unternehmen wird höher bewertet als
der amerikanische automobilriese GM
2020 verzeichnete das Unternehmen eine
rekordnachfrage seine Modellpalette
hatte ein jährliches Wachstum von 121 %.
und mit der Markteinführung der et7
Limousine Anfang 2021 machte die Aktie
sofort einen weiteren Sprung
ähnlich wie tesla hat sich das
Unternehmen in einigen Bereichen als
digitaler Premium
elektrofahrzeughersteller präsentiert
aber sie versuchen auch das Produkt für
Chinas Mittelschicht attraktiver zu
machen
wir sind uns von Anfang an über unsere
Zielgruppe im Klaren der Preis unseres
basiert auf den meistverkauften Mittel
und Oberklasse Limousinen in China wie
zum Beispiel der Fünferreihe von BMW
Audi A6 oder der Mercedes-Benz E-Klasse
[Musik]
aber Neo geht nicht immer den Weg des
Erfolgs es gibt einen Grund warum
iv-aktien so volatil sind und zwar weil
diese Unternehmen über Nacht vor dem
Bankrott stehen können Neo war da keine
Ausnahme
es handelte sich um ein kleines relativ
neues Autounternehmen das Anfang des
Jahres mit großen Rückrufaktionen
aufgrund von Bränden zu kämpfen hatte
die Verkäufe ging daraufhin zurück
außerdem trat sein größter Konkurrent
Tesla 2019 in den chinesischen Markt ein
Team neben der Konkurrenz durch Tesla
stagnierte der Absatz von Elektroautos
im Jahr 2019 auch aufgrund von
Entscheidungen der chinesischen
Regierung die chinesische Regierung hat
die direkten Subventionen für
Elektroautos im Jahr 2019 um mehr als
50% gekürzt das ist bis jetzt die größte
subventionskürzung
doch Anfang 2020 wendete sich das Blatt
während Chinas Subventionskürzungen fast
das Ende für Neo bedeuteten retteten
Investitionen einer chinesischen Provinz
das Unternehmen
Neo gelang es eine Vereinbarung mit der
chinesischen Stadt hey Fay zu treffen
im Februar 2020 konnte nio so sein
Cashflow aufrecht erhalten was ihn half
ihre Probleme in den Griff zu bekommen
Teil der Vereinbarung war nios Hauptsitz
in der Stadt hey Fay einzurichten einem
Gebiet für wirtschaftliche und
technologische Entwicklung auch wurde
den InvestorInnen ein Anteil von
24,1% gewährt diese waren zuversichtlich
dass Neo nachdem die Liquiditätsprobleme
in den Hintergrund getreten waren
endlich nach vorne schauen und die
Produktion steigern würde
für Tesla waren Produktionssteigerungen
ein großes Problem denn mask versuchte
mit Tesla nicht nur das Auto neu zu
erfinden sondern auch den gesamten
autoherstellungsprozess
und von der Herstellung erhofft sich Neo
seinen Wettbewerbsvorteil der News SUV
S6 kostet ein Drittel mehr als die
Limousine Model 3 von Tesla nio nutzt
deshalb innovative Dienstleister um
seine Kosten zu senken der größte
Unterschied zwischen hier und Tesla
besteht darin dass Neo seine Fertigung
an ein Subunternehmen ausgelagert hat
das über mehr Erfahrungen den Bereich
verfügt
ein weiterer großer Unterschied ist das
Abonnement-Modell von Neo es soll den
Kundinnen die Angst vor dem
batteriebesitz und deren Risiken nehmen
Kundinnen brauchen hierzu nur das Auto
ohne Batterie zu kaufen die Batterie
können Sie dann ganz einfach gegen eine
monatliche Gebühr von neomieten
der letzte Unterschied zwischen Tesla
und Neo besteht darin wie beide das
Problem der Reichweite angehen die
größte Sorge für iv-kunden ist dass Ihre
Batterie leer sein könnte bevor sie ihr
Ziel erreichen
Mio stellt seinen käufer:innen einen
batteriewechselservice zur Verfügung
Neuwagen können hier an eine Art
Hausstation fahren und in wenigen
Minuten die leere Batterie durch eine
vollständig geladene Batterie ersetzen
Neo gibt an bereits an einer zweiten
Generation von Ladestationen zu arbeiten
300 weitere Stationen dieser Art sollen
in China eröffnet werden der chinesische
Markt für Elektrofahrzeuge soll 2021 auf
1,8 Millionen Fahrzeuge anwachsen doch
die Konkurrenz wächst nio wird nicht nur
mit Tesla und anderen chinesischen
hersteller:innen konkurrieren müssen
herstellerinnen der ganzen Welt setzen
auf den chinesischen Markt für
Elektrofahrzeuge und erkennen das
Wachstumspotenzial
ob Neo sich nicht nur den heimischen
Markt sichern kann sondern auch
international ein Global Player wird
bleibt abzuwarten
die hersteller:innen bewegen sich alle
in die gleiche Richtung weg vom
Verbrennungsmotor aber es gibt eine
Technologie die es schon seit den 90er
Jahren gibt sich aber bisher nicht
durchsetzen konnte Wasserstoff
2020 war definitiv das Jahr des
batterieautos aber was ist mit seinem
grünen Pendant der Wasserstoff
Brennstoffzelle
Präsident George W Bush berühmte einst
die Wasserstofftechnologie Elon Masken
gegen verspottete sie als unglaublich
dumm die Autofabriken sind gespalten
Tesla und VW sind die Ivy Champions
Honda Hyundai und Toyota setzen auf
Wasserstoff sehen wir uns an wie beides
im Vergleich abschneidet die Reichweite
war schon immer der Hauptkritikpunkt in
dieser Hinsicht scheinen
wasserstoffzellen die Oberhand zu haben
während das 75
000 $ teure Tesla Modell es long range
mit einer einzigen Ladung 375 Meilen
weit kommt bewegen sich billigere Autos
im Bereich von 100 bis 200 Meilen die
durchschnittliche Reichweite eines
wasserstoffzellenautos beträgt etwa 250
Meilen und laut der britischen
Fachzeitschrift autocar übertrifft der
nexo SUV von Hyundai den Tesla mit einer
realen Reichweite von 414 Meilen
während das Aufladen eines
Elektrofahrzeugs stundendauern kann
lassen sich wasserstoffzellen im besten
Fall in derselben zeitauftanken wie ein
Benzinfahrzeug was Brennstoffzellen
derzeit noch zu schaffen macht sind die
Kosten und die Effizienz laut der Horvat
und Partners haben batteriebetriebene
Elektroautos einen Wirkungsgrad von 70
bis 80%, das heißt von der
Stromerzeugung durch Turbinen oder
Kraftwerke bis zum Fahrzeug es geht
wenig Energie verloren der Wirkungsgrad
von wasserstofffahrzeugen liegt dagegen
nur bei 25 bis 35%. der elektrolytische
Prozess zur Herstellung von Wasserstoff
gefolgt von der Komprimierung und dem
Transport des Gases kostet Zeit und Geld
so dass ein wasserstofffahrzeug für die
gleiche Strecke wie ein Elektrofahrzeug
etwa dreimal so viel Energie benötigt
die Effizienz und die hohen
Wartungskosten von Wasserstoffautos
haben den Kampf zugunsten von
batteriebetriebenen Elektrofahrzeugen
für den PKW weitgehend entschieden
Batterien haben jedoch eine Nachteil bei
Kapazitätserhöhung sinkt die Reichweite
Brennstoffzellen hingegen können ihre
Reichweite wie Benziner erhöhen man baut
einfach einen größeren Tank
dies eignet sich für Nutzfahrzeuge sogar
für Schiffe und den Luftverkehr und
genau in diesen Bereich investieren
Hunde und Toyota die Frage ist also
nicht entweder Batterien oder
wasserstoffzellen auf dem Weg zu einer
umweltfreundlichen Mobilität werden
beide benötigt
soviel zu den Vor- und Nachteilen bei
der Antriebsarten aber lassen Sie uns
die Unternehmen näher betrachten die
sich auf Wasserstoff konzentriert haben
hierzu ist uns River Davis aus Tokyo
zugeschaltet fangen wir mit der
Wissenschaft dahinter an wie wird
Wasserstoff eigentlich hergestellt
wasserstoff ist wirklich erstaunlich da
ist das am häufigsten vorkommen der
Elemente auf unserer Erde ist das aber
nur in verbindung wie zum Beispiel mit
Wasser vorkommt muss der reine
Wasserstoff der in Brennstoffzellen
verwendet werden kann erst hergestellt
werden
[Musik]
es gibt mehrere gängige Verfahren zur
Herstellung von Wasserstoff ein wirklich
interessantes Verfahren ist die
Elektrolyse dabei wird Wasser mit Hilfe
von Elektrizität in Wasserstoff und
Sauerstoff aufgespalten
sehr interessant an diesem Verfahren ist
dass bei der Erzeugung von Strom aus
erneuerbaren Energien wie Wind oder
Sonne während des gesamten Prozesses der
Wasserstoffherstellung keine Kohlenstoff
Emissionen entstehen
wir hören ja viel über easy-unternehmen
viele investieren in Batterie Antriebe
aber welche etablierten Autokonzerne
investieren speziell in Wasserstoff
drei große Namen die hier genannt werden
müssen wenn man über Brennstoffzellen in
Personenverkehr spricht sind Toyota
Hyundai und Honda diese Unternehmen
haben jetzt bereits kommerzielle
Brennstoffzellenfahrzeuge auf dem Markt
und setzen sich vom Rest der Branche ab
die sich zunehmend auf Batterien
konzentriert
wie zum Beispiel General Motors Ford
oder Mercedes-Benz alle diese
Automobilhersteller wendeten sich von
Wasserstoff ab und konzentrieren sich
nun auf Batterien
in der Vergangenheit lag die Hoffnung
bei Personenkraftwagen auf Wasserstoff
aber in Zukunft werden diese beiden
Technologien einen anderen Platz
einnehmen
der Markt und sogar Akteure wie Toyota
sind sich einig das Batterien bei
Personenkraftwagen eine größere Rolle
spielen
wenn es um langstreckentransporter oder
schwere und große Fahrzeuge wird eher
Wasserstoff eine führende Rolle spielen
das legt an seiner hohen Energiedichte
die für Busse oder Lastkraftwagen eher
geeignet ist um längere Strecken zu
bewältigen im Vergleich zu Benzin hat
Wasserstoff etwa die dreifache
Energiemenge pro Gewichtseinheit mit dem
Toyota Mirai kann man so bis zu 850 km
weit fahren
es handelt sich also um einen sehr
Energiedichten Kraftstoff der in Zukunft
in größeren Fahrzeugen eine Rolle
spielen wird und sogar darüber hinaus
viele Analysten sind der Meinung dass
Wasserstoff in 20 Jahren sogar in der
Schifffahrt oder in Flugzeugen eine
entscheidende Rolle spielen wird
riverdales unsere Reporterin in Tokio
vielen Dank für Ihre Zeit
wie verstopfte Arterien unsere Mobilität
trägt zum raschen Klimawandel bei nach
Angaben der Vereinten Nationen entfallen
fast 25 Prozent der Emissionen auf Autos
Busse und LKWs hinzu kommt der Faktor Öl
in den USA gibt es bereits Anzeichen
eines Zenits unsichere geopolitische
Risiken könnten die Volatilität des
Ölpreises befeuern dies bringt uns dazu
über unsere Abhängigkeit vom Öl
nachzudenken sind Elektrofahrzeuge die
Antwort auf dieses Problem
ich denke es ist finanziell unsinnig
irgendetwas anderes als ein Elektroauto
zu kaufen das durch Autonomie
aufgerüstet werden kann
Elon muskalten er hat seit zehn Jahren
die richtige Idee und während andere
Autohersteller versuchen aufzuholen sind
Elektrofahrzeuge längst einer der
innovativsten Märkte überhaupt
schon im 19 Jahrhundert waren bereits
viele Autos mit Elektroantrieb unterwegs
und wurden in Zeitungsanzeigen wie hier
in Pittsburgh beworben doch 1908 führte
Henry Ford das gasbetriebene Model T1
bis 1927 perfektionierte fort das
Fließband und baute rund 15 Millionen
Models erst am Mitte der 60er Jahre
sehen wir wieder Elektroautos meist sind
das Konzeptmodelle wie der Hennig
Kilowatt in den späten 90ern auch
bekommt die Welt einen ersten Eindruck
von Hybriden darunter der Toyota Prius
der im Jahr 2000 in die amerikanischen
Autohäuser rollt drei Jahre später wird
Tesla gegründet und 2008 stellt das
Unternehmen den Tesla Roadster davor es
folgen das Model SXT und weitere Modelle
gleichzeitig erweist sich Asien als
starker Konkurrent der Nissan Lee für
2010 zumeist verkauften Elektroauto der
Welt und China zum größten Markt für
Elektroautos zu den Investoren gehören
Jack ma und
das alles bringt uns zum heutigen Tag
Bloomberg new energy finance geht davon
aus dass China in vier Jahren mehr als 3
Millionen Elektrofahrzeuge verkaufen
wird in den USA werden bis zum Jahr 2021
schätzungsweise eine Million ew-modelle
auf den Straßen unterwegs sein aber wie
genau funktioniert ein Elektroauto und
was ist drin hier gibt es Antworten
Elektrofahrzeuge Autos die mit Batterien
betrieben werden sie funktionieren auf
viele verschiedene Arten sehen wir uns
Tesla an ein Akku mit einer Reichweite
von 300 Meilen besteht aus 7000
Lithium-Ionen Zellen im Inneren der
Batterie winzige Lithium-Ionen bewegen
sich von der Kathode zur Anode die
Batterien bestehen aus Nickel Kobalt
Lithium und Aluminium
diese Batterien haben es in sich sie
haben eine hohe lade- und endladerate
sie produzieren also eine Menge Energie
und man kann sie oft wiederverwenden um
eine Überhitzung der Batterie zu
vermeiden wird bei der
Wechselstromtechnik eine kühle
Flüssigkeit verwendet die zwischen den
Batterien fließt der Wechselrichter
nimmt diese Energie auf und wandelt sie
in Wechselstrom um eine Art Spannung die
sich ständig ändert
von dort aus erzeugt er ein rotierendes
Magnetfeld im Motor und Energie entsteht
der Antriebsstrang verteilt diese
Energie auf die Räder Strom der nicht
verbraucht wird z.B beim Bremsen wird in
die Batterie zurückgespeist der 36.000
$ teure Chevy wollt kommt mit einer
Akkuladung 238 meilenweit ein Tesla
Model S schafft 315 Meilen danach kann
man das Auto in etwa 30 Minuten an einer
Station aufladen zu Hause kann es bis zu
einem Tag dauern der Klo ist dass die
Batterie niedrig und flach auf der
Unterseite des Autos sitzt
ähnlich wie bei einem Skateboard der
niedrige Schwerpunkt sorgt für ein
besseres Fahrgefühl aber rechnet sich
das auch die durchschnittlichen Kosten
für Benzin in den USA liegen bei zwei
Dollar 55 pro Gallone bei Elektroautos
liegen sie bei $21 also 50% weniger
allerdings umso weiter man fährt desto
teurer ist das Auto Preis liegen
zwischen 30.000 und 180.000 Dollar aber
der Hype ist groß die Persönlichkeiten
sind groß einer der ist genau wissen
sollte ist einer der mittlerweile
reichsten Menschen der Welt Elon Musk
aber wer ist dieser Elon Musk eigentlich
[Applaus]
der Milliardär und Unternehmer Elon Musk
lässt seinen Worten Taten folgen ich
stehe persönlich und mit meinem ganzen
Vermögen für meine Produkte ein
sein größtes Kapital ist seine Fähigkeit
seine Visionen und Träume zu
verwirklichen und andere Menschen davon
zu überzeugen
entschlossen konnte er mit seinen
Visionen gleich drei Branchen verändern
ich wünsche allen Beteiligten viel Glück
und drückt uns die Daumen da kommt ein
Typ aus Südafrika nach Amerika und sagt
weißt du NASA diese ganze raketensache
ich glaube ich habe etwas besseres und
dafür riskierte er alles
wir hatten gerade mal Geld für etwa eine
Woche damals musste ich ein Entscheidung
treffen entweder nahm ich das gesamte
Kapital dass ich durch den Verkauf von
Paypal am ebay übrig hatte und
investierte es in Tesla oder Tesla Vera
am Ende
andere waren nicht bereit dieses Risiko
mit ihm oder seinen Firmen einzugehen
doch seine Rechnung ging auf wir haben
nicht nur das Kapital zurückgezahlt wir
haben es mit Zinsen und einer
Bonuszahlung zurückgezahlt letztendlich
hat der US-Steuerzahler also einen
Gewinn von mehr als 20 Millionen Dollar
aus diesem Darlehen gezogen doch Elon
Musk hat Visionen die ihn vielleicht
dorthin bringen wo vor ihm niemand war
er geht immer einen Schritt weiter sein
Ziel der Mars auf lange Sicht würde ich
wirklich gerne zum Mars fliegen das ist
das übergreifende Ziel von SpaceX
als ich ein kleines Kind war hatte ich
wirklich Angst vor der Dunkelheit aber
dann habe ich verstanden dass Dunkelheit
eigentlich nur die Abwesenheit von
Photonen im sichtbaren
Wellenlängenbereich zwischen 400 bis 700
Nanometer bedeutet es ist schwer zu
glauben dass der Unternehmer Elon Musk
jemals Angst vor etwas hatte
dann dachte ich das ist doch albern
Angst vor einem Mangel an Photonen zu
haben und danach hatte ich keine Angst
mehr vor der Dunkelheit
ein Kind sagte zu ihm sie dir den Mond
an er ist Millionen Kilometer entfernt
ilon sagte nein eigentlich weniger als
250.000 Meilen und sie sagten
Elon Musk hat sein Leben damit verbracht
den Leuten zu beweisen dass sie falsch
liegen Mars wuchs in Südafrika auf war
das Älteste von drei Kindern und wurde
ein Jahr früher eingeschult sein Vater
war Ingenieur seine Mutter May war Model
und Ernährungsberaterin
er war der jüngste und der kleinste aber
ein äußerst brillanter junge deshalb war
er bei einigen Leuten nicht sehr
ich war ein Bücherwurm und
wahrscheinlich auch ein kleiner
Besserwisser was natürlich für ein Kind
schwierig werden kann also habe ich
einfach viele Bücher gelesen und
versucht den Leuten in der Schule aus
dem Weg zu gehen
sein Sozialleben war viel weniger
ausgeprägt als dass meine anderen beiden
Kinder eben ein typischer Nerd ich habe
alle Comics gelesen die ich im Laden
oder in der Buchhandlung finden konnte
ich las alles was ich in die Finger
bekam von morgens bis abends irgendwann
ging mir die Bücher aus und ich begann
Enzyklopädien zu lesen
und der hat ein fotografisches
Gedächtnis so dass er sich alles merken
kann immer wenn ich eine Frage hatte
sagte meine Tochter Tosca fragilon
sein Bruder kindle-maske als er zehn
Jahre alt war wurde er getestet und man
stellte fest dass er eine der größten
Begabungen für das Programmieren von
Computern hatte ich versuchte einige
Computerkurse zu besuchen aber ich war
dem Lehrer weit voraus also fing ich an
ein Weltraumspiel namens Blaster zu
programmieren Mast fing an wie ein
Unternehmer zu denken und fand heraus
wie er sein Spiel verkaufen könnte aber
ich war 12 und wusste nicht wie
wir beschlossen in der Nähe unserer
Highschool eine Spielhalle zu eröffnen
wir waren große Fans von Videospielen
wir dachten es wird ein riesiger Erfolg
wir mieteten also ein Gebäude besorgten
die Spielhalle und kümmerten uns um die
Lieferung der Geräte am Ende mussten wir
nur noch die Genehmigung der Stadt
einholen aber die Genehmigung der Stadt
muss von einem Erwachsenen beantragt
werden und ihre Eltern hatten sie nicht
eingeweiht natürlich sagte man uns dass
wir keine Spielhalle eröffnen würden
max-chefkin ist ein Technologie und
Wirtschaftsjournalist der Elon Musk
bereits mehrfach porträtiert hat das
Erstaunlichste an seiner Kindheit ist
wohl seine Flucht aus Südafrika
ich weiß noch wie großartig ich damals
Amerika fand hier gibt es mehr
Möglichkeiten als in jedem anderen Land
der Welt Amerika ist das Land der
unbegrenzten Möglichkeiten
durch seine Auswanderung konnte Musk
auch seiner Dienstpflicht in der
südafrikanischen Armee entgehen
im Südafrika der Apartheid aufzuwachsen
war ziemlich so real ich meine wir haben
diese Regierung nicht unterstützt und
nicht an sie geglaubt somit stand die
Idee zum Militärdienst zu gehen wirklich
nicht zur Debatte ich erzählte meinen
Eltern dass ich nach Kanada gehen würde
sie versuchten mich natürlich davon zu
überzeugen nicht zu gehen und schon flog
er los ich dachte wow so unabhängig doch
als er gelandet war rief er mich an und
fragte und jetzt
was soll ich sagen von Montreal nach
Vancouver konnte ich Kanada vom Highway
Aussehen
er hielt sich mit Gelegenheit Jobs über
Wasser bevor er ans Queens College in
Toronto gehen an der Uni war ich nur
selten beim Unterricht ich habe nur das
Lehrbuch gelesen und mich auf Prüfungen
vorbereitet der große Reiz an der Uni
war dass ich dort Mädchen in meinem
Alter treffen konnte so wie meine erste
Frau
nach einem Abschluss in Ingenieurs und
Wirtschaftswissenschaften erhielt ihr
ein Stipendium für Stanford doch Silicon
Valley war the place to be
ich wollte einfach dorthin gehen wo die
wirklich spannenden Dinge stattfanden
Elon hatte die Fähigkeit sich die Welt
anzuschauen und zu sagen das kann in 20
Jahren ein echtes Problem werden
er sah sich um und stellte fest dass die
Welt verändernden Dinge nicht ins
Stanford stattfanden
ich bin nicht einmal zur Vorlesung
gegangen ich rief den Vorsitzenden des
Fachbereichs an und sagte ich möchte es
mit meinem eigenen Internet Unternehmen
versuchen und wenn es scheitert möchte
ich sicherstellen dass ich trotzdem
zurückkommen kann meine Kinder machen
komische Sachen aber ich habe mir nie
große Sorgen um sie gemacht wenn Elan
das College verlassen wollte konnte er
jederzeit wieder zurück mein Bruder war
zu der Zeit in Kanada und ich meinte ich
denke wir sollten versuchen ein
Internetunternehmen zu gründen also kam
er und schloss sich mir an er hatte
gerade mal 2000 Dollar keine Freunde
kaum genug Geld für eine Wohnung ich
glaube er erzählte mir dass er im
Fitnessstudio Dusche weil es dort wo er
wohnte keine Dusche gab wir haben
einfach ein paar Futons besorgt die
tagsüber als Couch dienten und sich
nachts in Betten verwandeln ließen steve
jarvinson ist risikoinvestor im Silicon
Valley ich traf Elon und seinen Bruder
Kimble zum ersten Mal Mitte der 90er
Jahre ich glaube sie waren etwa eine
Woche hier und stellten gerade ihr neues
Unternehmen namens SIP vor in den späten
90ern gab es einen regelrechten
Goldrausch die Leute strömten nach
Silicon Valley um im Internetgeschäft
Fuß zu fassen und reich zu werden
mask hatte die Idee Anzeigen zu
digitalisieren er nahm eine CD der
Gelben Seiten eine Kartensoftware
schrieb ein wenig Code und fügte alles
zusammen um die ersten onlinestätte
Anzeigen zu erstellen
war visionär und Master meint ich habe
mich um den Verkauf gekümmert ich hatte
immer noch meine grundlegenden
Programmierkenntnisse so dass ich in der
Lage war die Software für unser erstes
Unternehmen zu schreiben als Elend damit
anfing war das Internet gerade mal ein
paar Jahre alt die meisten lokalen
Unternehmen waren nicht im Internet
vertreten wenn man nach einem Geschäft
suchte musste man die gelben Seiten
aufschlagen wir dachten uns das
Medienunternehmen wie Zeitungen Hilfe
brauchen um viele ihre Anzeigen in
Websites zu übertragen jemand hat uns
buchstäblich die gelben Seiten vor die
Füße geworfen und gefragt glauben Sie
dass Sie das jemals ersetzen werden und
wir dachten der Typ sei verrückt denn
das war ja erst der Anfang und ging noch
viel viel weiter
es dauerte nicht lange bis ich
Medienunternehmen aus dem ganzen Land
melden
so konnten wir die New York Times Hurst
night Ridder und eine Reihe anderer
Unternehmen als Investoren und Kunden
gewinnen
1999 kaufte dann Alter Vista compact SIP
du für 300 7 Millionen Dollar in bar und
34 Millionen in Aktienoptionen mask war
damals gerade 28 Jahre alt
ich dachte das ist total verrückt dass
jemand so viel Geld für unser kleines
Unternehmen bezahlt von Norwegen über
Deutschland bis hin zu China wurden
Milliarden an Subventionen ausgegeben um
AutofahrerInnen zum Kauf von E-Autos zu
bewegen in China dem größten evimarkt
der Welt stiegen die Verkäufe von
Elektroautos Bussen und kommerziellen
ehefahrzeugen im Jahr 2018 auf 1,3
Millionen ein enormer Anstieg huanggang
gilt in China als Vater der Elektroautos
der Verkauf von Fahrzeugen mit der
erneuerbarer Energie ist um fast 60%
gestiegen dies zeigt dann sehr schnelles
Wachstum das zeigt uns dass wir auf
Autos mit erneuerbarer Energie setzen
sollten
[Musik]
heute sind es dieselben Sorgen wie in
den Siebzigern Verlässlichkeit und
kosten wenn Sie ein E-Auto für 30.000
Dollar kaufen kann es bis zu sechs
Jahren dauern bis sich diese
Investitionen amortisiert bessere
Batterien und mir Ladestation können
hier helfen
in der Zwischenzeit sitzen
Autohersteller in der Falle sie
investieren Milliarden von Dollar um
ivis zu entwickeln die nicht rentabel
sind sie sind gezwungen Partnerschaft
mit Konkurrenten einzugehen um die
Rentabilität zu erhöhen wer auch immer
die richtige Formel findet könnte der
große Gewinner sein werden Sie an der
Spitze einer neuen Revolution stehen
oder werden Ihre Träume wie vor 100
Jahren zerschlagen
ford hat sich dazu verpflichtet bis 2030
kohlenstoffneutral zu sein damit sind
wir in unserer Branche führend denn wir
sind überzeugt dass die Zeit für die
Automobilindustrie reif
[Musik]
istion des Mustangs für Aufsehen
die Herausforderung für das Design
bestand darin das was bei
Elektrofahrzeugen fehlte mit der
Leidenschaft für Mustangs zu verbinden
20 sollen 40% der Modelle infiziert sein
wir gehen davon aus dass bis Mitte des
nächsten Jahrzehnts 50% der verkauften
Fahrzeuge bis zu einem gewissen Grad
elektrifiziert sein werden
es gibt natürlich einen großen Markt für
Hybridfahrzeuge und das wird auch in
Zukunft unsere dominierende Technologie
sein
Toyota hofft bis 2030 auf weltweit 5,5
Millionen Verkäufer
was ist das nächste große Ding für VW
und das ist es das Elektroauto das für
viele unserer Kunden wirklich die beste
Wahl ist
volkswagen hat gerade sein Budget um 36
Prozent auf 60 Milliarden Euro erhöht um
bis 2025 80 neue Modelle zu produzieren
etwa 15 bis 16 Prozent unserer Verkäufe
werden auf E-Fahrzeuge entfallen es wird
eine neue Welle eine Revolution kommen
und wenn sie da ist wollen wir ganz vorn
dabei sein mit Modellen unter 33.000
Dollar versuchen bisschen Budget Markt
zu erobern audi wird in nur fünf Jahren
20 Modelle auf den Markt bringen man
sieht einen Trend zur Elektrifizierung
einen Trend zur Konnektivität was kommt
also als nächstes eine Menge sehr viel
ivies haben sich seit dem Model t-stark
verändert wie geht es nun weiter
schauen wir uns Tesla an sie haben in
letzter Zeit Erfolge erzielt das Model
free ist das meistverkaufte Elektroauto
in den USA und liest die Konkurrenz
hinter sich noch ist Rentabilität ein
Problem je mehr Autos Tesla verkauft
desto mehr Geld verlieren sie der Umsatz
pro Einheit ist im dritten Quartal
weiter gefallen und setzt damit andere
Autohersteller unter Druck
immer stärkere Produkte werden auf den
Markt kommen auch die mag Durchdringung
nimmt zu es gibt unterschiedliche
Meinungen darüber wie schnell der Markt
wächst aber er wächst und wir müssen
unsere Anteile sichern
ich glaube nicht dass der größte
Konkurrent von Tesla Toyota oder General
Motors ist es werden die großen
Technologieunternehmen die eine Billion
Dollar oder mehr wert sind mehr als alle
Autofirmen zusammen das sind Unternehmen
die in der Lage sind Talente und Kapital
anzuziehen und die sich leisten können
Geld zu verlieren um es mit jemandem wie
Tesla aufzunehmen
eigentlich perfekt oder die Leute wollen
die Autos die Autofirmen liefern fertig
leider nicht denn hier ist das Problem
Konzerne müssen rund 141 Milliarden
Dollar für die Elektrifizierung ihrer
Flotte ausgeben man schätzt dass die
Produktion eines ivis 12.000 Dollar
teurer ist als die eines Benziners also
ein henna-ei-problem die Konzerne
brauchen der Käuferinnen diese brauchen
mehr Auswahl um überzeugt zu werden das
bedeutet auch mehr Verlust aufgrund der
Produktionskosten
unternehmen müssen die Kosten für Teile
wie Batterien senken analysten schätzen
dass dies noch mehr als 5 Jahre dauern
könnte in der Zwischenzeit sind sie
gezwungen Partnerschaften einzugehen um
die Rentabilität zu steigern pSA echner
Peugeot will bis 2023 80 Prozent seiner
Modelle elektrisch betreiben und sich
hierzu mit vier zusammenschließen um die
Kosten zu senken
dieser Wandel in der Branche wird für
viele OEMs eine Herausforderung
darstellen es wird eine lawinistische
Phase geben die nächsten Jahre werden
schwierig
ich denke die Vorstellung dass ein
einzelnes Unternehmen alleine in diese
neue Zukunft investieren wird ist sehr
unwahrscheinlich
fort und VW kooperieren um elektrische
autonome Autos zu entwickeln
der Geschäftsmann in ihnen würde so
etwas nicht tun aber ihre
Führungspersönlichkeit verlangt es von
ihnen
fort wird batterie-autos auf einer
vw-plattform bauen und VW wird 2,6
Milliarden Dollar in die vortochter Argo
investieren selbst für zwei so große
Unternehmen ist es sinnvoll sich einen
Teil der Anstrengungen zu teilen damit
sie schneller und effizienter werden
VW und sein chinesischer Partner
investieren bis 2020 mehr als 4,4
Milliarden Dollar in die Produktion der
Markt um sofort zu wachsen ist bereits
da und es ermöglicht diesen Unternehmen
schneller mit erschwinglicher
Technologie auf den Markt zu kommen die
verschafft Ihnen jetzt vielleicht sogar
einen kleinen Wettbewerbsvorteil
gegenüber denen die es ein paar Jahre
allein versuchen
ich glaube niemand investiert gerne in
eine ungewisse Zukunft doch was bleibt
ihnen übrig die IV ist die bisher auf
den Markt gekommen sind konnten Tesla
nicht vom Thron stoßen mercedes hat
seine ewus-debüge gerade um ein Jahr
verschoben um die Nachfrage zu
befriedigen sind die Originalteile
Hersteller OEMs also aufeinander
angewiesen laut McKinsey können zwei von
ihnen die gemeinsam eine spezielle Evi
Plattform entwickeln die Kosten um 1.500
bis 2 000 $ pro Auto senken viele dieser
Partnerschaften sind bisher mit
batteriefirmen geschlossen worden
Volkswagen BMW Volvo und Tesla schließen
batterieverträge im Wert von mehreren
Milliarden Dollar ab um sich Kapazitäten
zu sichern gM hat sich mit LG chemical
zusammengetan um eine Fabrik für
Elektroautos in Ohio zu bauen sie müssen
Kosten senken und Synergien finden umso
mehr Geld für Investitionen freizusetzen
einige Autofirmen sind wirklich spät
dran und haben akzeptiert dass sie sich
in dieser Hinsicht voll engagieren
müssen
aber Sie werden viel Unterstützung durch
Behörden und Regierungen benötigen das
wird leider nicht einfach sein
Volvo und Chili fusionieren und lernen
bis 2025 jedes Jahr ein neues IV Modell
auf den Markt zu bringen um seine
CO2-Bilanz zu verringern ergeben sie
fast 50 Milliarden Dollar aus auf der
Consumer Electronics Show in Las Vegas
waren Amazon Intro qualcam und
Blackberry mit datenverarbeitenden
Dienstleistungen wie verbesserten Chips
und Sensoren für autonome Autos die
Technik kann bei der Kartierung und
Navigationssystemen helfen laut Ente
wird dieser Markt bis 2030 einen Wert
von dreieinhalb Milliarden pro Jahr
erreichen es ist ein Computer auf Rädern
es ist ein Gerät das über seine Funktion
als Mobilgerät hinaus vertrieben werden
kann
letztes Jahr wurden weltweit mehr als 2
Millionen Elektroautos gekauft im Jahr
2025 sollen es um die 10 und 2014 sogar
56 Millionen werden Tendenz steigend
aber Elektroautos müssen billiger werden
35% des Preises machen momentan noch die
Batterien aus diese Linie hier zeigt
Kosten eines normalen Verbrennungs
Motors und verdeutlicht das E-Fahrzeuge
bis 2024 noch immer teurer sein werden
dann tritt eine Wende ein ivies werden
viel billiger und die Kosten für
Batterien senken es gibt viele Faktoren
eine heimladestation verzögert die
Preisspanne um ein bis drei Jahre in
China wird es länger teurer bleiben weil
die Autopreise dort niedriger sind als
in anderen Ländern in den USA gibt es
Steuergutschriften von 20 bis 70.000
Dollar für die ersten 200.000 verkauften
Autos je nach Größe der Batterie
Bundesstaaten können auch
subventionieren zum Beispiel ein
Kalifornien wo die Verkäufe von
Elektroautos seit 2017 sprunghaft
angestiegen sind Kalifornien ist somit
der zweitgrößte Käufer von Elektroautos
der Welt
Sport
[Musik]
ohne eine deutliche Steigerung von
Elektrofahrzeugen werden wir unsere
Lüfte den Großstädten nur schwer sauber
halten wir müssen also die Werbetrommel
rühren und müssen nach unserem Geld auch
Taten folgen lassen indem wir Anreize
schaffen
Mary Nickels Vorsitzende der
kalifornischen luftreinhaltungsbehörde
und treibende Kraft für saubere Luft
es ist nicht nur der finanzieller Anreiz
der größte Anreiz ist die Tatsache dass
man einen Aufkleber für die
fahrgemeinschaftsspur bekommt auch wenn
man nur Einzelfahrer ist das ist das was
mehr Pendler aus der Mittelschicht dazu
bewegt hat sich für das elektrische
Fahren zu entscheiden
454 Milliarden dollarplan bei dem Kunden
einen Bargeld Gutschein erhalten wenn
sie ältere Benzinautos gegen
Elektroautos oder andere Hybridfahrzeuge
eintauschen Tom Peil Präsident der
American energy Alliance hält nichts von
Subventionen und ist Befürworter der
freien Marktwirtschaft
einer der Autoren Senator Hedges sagte
wir begrenzen die Zahl der Fahrzeuge auf
200.000 pro Unternehmen weil wir nicht
wollen dass alle von den Subventionen
abhängig werden
wir wollen die Technologie vorantreiben
und dann die Industrie von dort aus
weitermachen lassen
Subventionen können immer auch in
falsche Hände geraten die
Aufsichtsbehörde tieri GTA hat
festgestellt dass 70 Millionen Dollar an
Autokäufer gezahlt wurden trotz
unzulässiger Anträge warum ist noch
unklar die Ars aber hat bisher keine
Möglichkeit solche Fälle zu verhindern
Senator Bill Cassidy kritisierte die
Kredite man müsste sicherstellen dass
Sie wisst von wohlhabenden gekauft und
nur für weniger wohlhabende
subventioniert würden
war meines unterm Strich sollte sich die
Regierung nicht damit befassen Gewinner
und Verlierer der Branche herauszupicken
aber selbst mit Subventionen erreich
te das in den letzten zehn Jahren nur
zwei Prozent der gesamten Autoverkäufe
und dann ist dann noch Europa die
Verkäufe sind jetzt 2019 sprunghaft
angestiegen in Norwegen sind 42 Prozent
der Neuwagenverkäufe Evis Norwegens ziel
ist es bis 2025 alle Neuwagenverkäufe
immissionsfrei zu gestalten die
Europäische Kommission übt gerade viel
Druck aus um ihre CO2-Emissionen zu
verringern die Ziele der nächsten 20 30
Jahre können ohne E-Fahrzeuge nicht
erreicht werden Verbesserungen am
Verbrennungsmotor alleine werden hier
nicht ausreichen
Europa Norwegen und andere dieser Länder
sind ganz anders strukturiert ihre
Bürger haben eine viel höhere Toleranz
gegenüber steuern und der Einmischung
des Staates in ihr Leben es ist ein ganz
anderer Markt ein viel kleineres Land
sie konzentrieren sich mehr in den
städtischen Gebieten
Norwegen ist führend bei der
Mehrwertsteuer
befreite Lebensmittel dafür werden
höhere Steuern auf Benzinfahrzeuge
erhoben was VerbraucherInnen dazu zwingt
sich für Evis zu entscheiden Deutschland
hat Norwegen beim Verkauf von ivis knapp
überholt das Land hat außerdem 54
Milliarden Euro für den Kampf gegen den
Klimawandel bereitgestellt teilweise
sind die Subventionen für ivis der Bonus
von bis zu 57.000 € wird zur Hälfte von
der Autoindustrie getragen damit sollen
bis zu 700.000 E-Fahrzeuge gefördert
werden sie betrachten den ganzen
Automarkt in Deutschland Frankreich oder
UK beträgt der Anteil an den Verkäufen
immer noch wenige Prozent denn auch
schnell steigend
China begann 2009 mit der
Subventionierung von Eva Zeugen für ihre
öffentlichen flotten 2013 dann auch für
endverbraucherinnen 5000 bis 8.500 $ je
nach Reichweite des Autos werden direkt
an den Hersteller gezeigt bis 2025
sollen 7 Millionen ivis Hybride und
Brennstoffzellenautos auf den Markt
kommen
[Musik]
china hat mehr als 30 Milliarden Dollar
für die Subventionierung ausgegeben die
Verkäufe sind seitdem sprunghaft
angestiegen nun hat China die
Subventionen um 50% reduziert
2021 sollen sie vollständig Auslaufen
die Auswirkungen sehen wir bereits die
Verkäufe sind darauf sechs Monate in
Folge zurückgegangen
die in den nächsten 12 bis 24 Monaten
drastisch gekürzten und damit
wegfallenden Subventionen werden sich
auch auf die marktneulinge auswerten
Brian Go ist ehemaliger Wall Street
Baker und jetzt Präsident von expen in
China
diese neuen Akteure werden nicht das
Zeitfenster haben dass wir hatten nur
mit Unterstützung der Regierung in den
Markt zu kommen und einer sehr geringen
staatlichen Unterstützung konfrontiert
sein
[Musik]
China entschied sich nun gegen
Subventionskürzungen und willst
zusätzlich mehr Geld in den Ausbau von
Ladestationen stecken china hat acht Mal
so viel Ladestation wie die USA je
dunkler das rosa desto mehr Ladestation
und fast alle befinden sich in
Kalifornien
langfristig wird die Maßnahme dem
gesamten Sektor zugute kommen denn die
Subventionen selbst kommen den Anbietern
des unteren Marktsegments zugute die
Abschaffung oder Kürzung der
Subventionen zwingt die Verbraucher sich
auf die Produkte Differenzierung die
Qualität und das Leistungsversprechen zu
konzentrieren
in den USA ist es ähnlich sollte ein
Konzern
zweierkäufe erreichen fallen sub
vention hatte erreicht und mussten nun
einen Rückgang ihrer quartalsumsätze
hinnehmen
letzten Endes erhalten die Konzerne die
Subventionen wenn auch nicht direkt es
ist der einzige Weg Elektroautos mit
Profi zu verkaufen in der Anfangsphase
sind Subventionen also unumgänglich wenn
man diese Subventionen abschafft werden
die Autohersteller versuchen ein
besseres Produkt auf den Markt zu
bringen das erschwinglicher ist
man überlegt diese Kredite bis 2024 zu
verlängern und erst ab 600.000
verkauften Fahrzeugen zu begrenzen
Unternehmen wie Tesla würde dies viel
mehr Spielraum geben Elon Musk feiert in
Shanghai seine erste testerfabrik
außerhalb der USA Tesla könnte so zu
einem der dominierenden Wettbewerber für
Evies auf der ganzen Welt werden
Elektroautos machen 5% der
Neuwagenverkäufe in China aus die
Regierung möchte diesen Anteil auf 25%
steigern die Bekämpfung der
Umweltverschmutzung ist eine Priorität
für Präsident
jeder Schaden den wir der Natur zufügen
wird irgendwann auf uns zurückfallen das
ist eine Realität der wir uns stellen
müssen
in China sterben viele Menschen an
Lungenkrebs oder Schlaganfällen die auf
die hohe Luftverschmutzung
zurückzuführen sind
China ist bei der Einführung der
elektrofahrzeugtechnologie führend und
sieht auch seine Zukunft in der
iw-branche
genug Geld ist vorhanden hunderte von
chinesischen Autofirmen werden von
Milliardären unterstützt alle wollen die
Nummer eins sein wie expen und sein
Model free ein Tesla Konkurrent der nur
halb so viel kostet wenn Sie zu den
Spitzenunternehmen gehören haben sie
keine Schwierigkeiten Kapital zu
beschaffen
investiert 2019 waren es mehr als 900
Millionen Dollar weitere 400 Millionen
aus Unternehmen wie expen hatte 2019
bisher 11.000 Autos verkauft treibende
Kraft war hier Wong Kong der 2011
chefwissenschaftler das evi-projekt
wurde
der Klimawandel liegt in unser aller
Verantwortung wir müssen begreifen dass
wir zu den weltweit größten
Produzenten gehören seit mehr als fünf
Jahren befassen wir uns intensiv mit
diesem Thema
china plant bis 2035 60 Prozent seiner
verkauften Autos mit Elektromotoren zu
betreiben außerdem wollen sie mindestens
20 neue Standorte für Auto- und andere
Industrie schaffen
wir sind in der Verantwortung im
Missionen zu reduzieren wir haben einen
Beitrag zur Ökologie und unserer
Zivilisation zu leisten
sehr verantwortungsbewusst wird aber
möglicherweise nicht jedem chinesischen
iv-unternehmen das Überleben sichern wie
Eric Chinas größter Hersteller von Ibis
rechnet mit einem Verlust Warren Buffett
meldete im Oktober einen Gewinnrückgang
von 89% und einem Gewinnrückgang von bis
zu 43% im Jahr 2019
dann ist da noch Neo das von ponymer und
seiner Firma Tencent unterstützt wird
2017 gab es eine Investition in Höhe von
einer Milliarden US-Dollar das
Unternehmen hatte allerdings in den
letzten Jahren Verluste von fast 6
Milliarden US-Dollar gemacht man kann
von einem vier oder fünfjährigen
Kleinkind nicht verlangen dass es Geld
verdient das ist bedenklich
Kostenüberschreitungen schwache
Verkäufer und eine Rückrufaktion für
etwa ein Viertel der fahrzeugezwangen
Neo etwa 20% seiner Belegschaft zu
entlassen Neo hat ca 1,7 Millionen Juan
Kosten pro Auto das für nur ein Drittel
der Kosten verkauft wird Werbeaktionen
wie 0% Zinsen und garantierte
Subventionen für Autos die vor Februar
zugelassen werden sollen Tesla den Kampf
ansagen wir beabsichtigen in China
weitere Investitionen zu tätigen und
auch zu erhöhen und Tesla ist nicht das
einzige ausländische Unternehmen audi
plant in den nächsten zwei Jahren neuen
weitere easy Modelle in China BMW wird
ab 2022 den Ei extrem
seines Minis
es geht nicht allein darum den
chinesischen Markt zu erobern wir wollen
auch Forschung und Entwicklung betreiben
das F&E Team wächst wir denken über ein
liefernetzwerk nach mit dem wir
gemeinsam intelligente Produkte
entwickeln
Daimler und Geli haben einen 780
Millionen Dollar Joint Venture gegründet
um zusammen an selbstfahrenden Autos zu
arbeiten wir werden gemeinsam den Smart
entwickeln und 2022 mit einer neuen
Produktgeneration am Markt sein wir sind
sehr gespannt darauf
wie schnell die Welt auf E-Fahrzeuge
umsteigt ist eine Frage des Geldes es
kann auch fünf bis sechs Jahre dauern
bis sich der Kauf eines 30 000 $ teuren
E-Autos in den USA lohnt die
Batteriepreise müssen sinken die
Batteriepreise sind seit 2010 um 89%
gesunken aber das wird sich
möglicherweise bald ändern das Problem
sind die lithiumproduzenten sie haben
ihre Produktion auf Hochtouren laufen
lassen weil sie auf eine steigende
Nachfrage durch Elektrofahrzeuge gesetzt
haben doch die erwartet hohe Nachfrage
blieb aus somit gab es niedrigere Preise
durch Überproduktion etwa 70% der
weltweiten Lithium vorkommen sind in der
Hand weniger Unternehmen in Südamerika
es wird durch traditionellen Bergbau
oder als Sole gefördert
werden große Mengen Wasser ins Erdreich
gepumpt und anschließend salzhaltiger
Schlamm abgetragen in großen Becken
gelagert verdampft die Sohle vor der
Verarbeitung es dauert drei bis fünf
Jahre bis eine neue Mine in Betrieb
gehen kann in den nächsten Jahren muss
viel investiert werden um die Nachfrage
zu decken
wir schätzen das bis 2025 rund 80
Prozent der Gesamtnachfrage auf
Elektroautos entfallen wird also ein
sehr großer Teil
Blumberg geht davon aus dass der Markt
für Lithium Batterien in 10 Jahren ein
Volumen von 116 Milliarden Dollar haben
könnte aber Preise müssen sinken 2019
kostete eine Batterieeinheit 156 Dollar
pro Kilowattstunde je billiger die
Batterie desto günstiger das Auto und
desto schneller die Akzeptanz
ein weiteres Problem von Lithium Kobalt
und Nickel ist dass sie möglicherweise
nicht so umweltfreundlich sind wie man
denkt das 20 Jahrhundert war das
Zeitalter des Verbrennungsmotors das 21
Jahrhundert wird der Batterie gehören
bis 2040 wird die Mehrheit der weltweit
verkauften Autos von Batterien
angetrieben werden die weit weniger
Schadstoffe ausstoßen als Benzinfresser
doch die in Batterien verwendeten
Elemente haben ihre eigenen
Herausforderungen Lithium benötigt viel
Wasser bei niedrigen lithiumpreisen
könnte sich der Bergbau nicht mehr
lohnen und die Industrie könnte auf die
ökologisch riskantere Methode setzen
Salzwasser in den Untergrund zu pumpen
um es als Sole zu gewinnen nickel wird
in Kathoden von Lithium-Ionen Batterien
verwendet um die Energiedichte zu
erhöhen so können ivis schneller und
weiterfahren doch sind
Bergbauunternehmen überhaupt in der Lage
eine stetige Nickel Lieferung zu
garantieren
[Musik]
Cobalt hat ein eher ethisches Problem es
schützt die Batterie beim Laden vor
Überhitzung doch die Bedingungen für
Bergleute im Kongo dem weltweit größten
Produzenten sind schrecklich einige der
Arbeiter sind gerade einmal vier Jahre
alt ein sauberes Auto bedeutet also
nicht immer dass es sauber hergestellt
wird
manchmal können Lithium-Ionen Batterien
in Brand geraten sie können sich
überhitzen und Sauerstoff freisetzen der
ein Feuer verursacht einige dieser
Brände lassen sich auf
Herstellungsfehler oder sogar auf
Überladung zurückführen eine mögliche
Lösung wäre die Flüssigkeit in Batterien
zu wechseln eine Alternative können
festkörperbatterien sein anstatt
Flüssigkeit enthalten diese Glaskeramik
oder ein anderes festes Material diese
könnten die Risiken einer
Entflammbarkeit verringern sowie dünnere
und kleinere Akkus ermöglichen die unter
den Autositz passen
ein weiteres Problem sind die
Ladestationen es gibt nicht genug und
die die es gibt sind nicht schnell genug
Ende 2018 gab es weltweit mehr als
630.000 Ladestationen 460.000 davon
allein in China nur ein Viertel der
Ladestationen gilt als schnell genug die
meisten legen eher im mittleren Bereich
die Autokonzerne kritisieren diese
Infrastruktur die momentan zu den
größten Hürden des evimark des zählt
wir müssen die Initiative ergreifen um
die Lade Infrastruktur zu verbessern ich
würde mich über eine stärkere
Zusammenarbeit in Europa und den
Regierungen der ganzen Welt freuen die
Infrastruktur die wir haben muss besser
werden wir werden Europa alle 120 km mit
Schnellladestationen ausstatten
wir bieten sowohl Ladestationen für das
eigene Haus als auch für öffentliche
Stromnetze an
es herrscht eine allgemeine Reichweiten
Phobie und der Grund dafür ist wie immer
die Lade Infrastruktur die nicht schnell
vorankommt
wir arbeiten eng mit die Herstellern
zusammen und fragen nach wie viele und
vor allem wo Evis im Umlauf sind um
unsere Ladestation zu platzieren wo sie
gebraucht werden somit können Käufer in
sicher sein dass eine Infrastruktur
vorhanden ist
easy go baut schnellladegeräte mit 50
Kilowatt und arbeitet mit Nissan und GM
zusammen wir arbeiten mit Lift und mit
Maven zusammen wir sind Teil des
leasingprogramms von GM die uber und
Lift Evis zur Verfügung stellt die
Entwicklung nimmt rasant zu und zwar
nicht nur in Kalifornien auch in Städten
wie Atlanta und Seattle
easygo hat inzwischen mehr als 1000
Ladestationen und konzentriert sich auf
den Einzelhandel wir haben eine
Kooperation mit Safeway wir sind Partner
von croger und Hofs sehr wichtige
Partner für Anwendungsfälle bei
Ladezeiten die Dauer eines Einkaufs sie
schließen ihr Auto in die Ladestation an
besorgen ihre Einkäufe kommen wieder
heraus und ihr Auto ist aufgeladen
ein anderer Anbieter ist
2001 gründeten die Mitglieder eines
solaren Teams eine Firma für
Ladestationen die in 10 Minuten mehr als
215 meilen reichweite bringen Tesla
verspricht eine Aufladung von 75 Meilen
in fünf Minuten
auch Lucid baut leichter Batterien für
Rennwagen mit einer Ladung erreicht man
eine Höchstgeschwindigkeit von 174
Meilen pro Stunde und eine um 20% höhere
batteriedichte der Einsatz dieser
Technologie könnte die
lade-infrastruktur grundlegend verändern
eine weitere Option ist das kontaktlose
Laden
seit über zehn Jahren versuchen wir das
kabellose Laden von Elektrofahrzeugen zu
perfektionieren
um mobile elektronische Geräte mit dem
Stromnetz zu verbinden
der Strom wird hier effizient über eine
Distanz zum Beispiel von einer Spule im
Boden ihrer Garage übertragen stellen
Sie sich ein Pad von der Größe eines
Pizzakartons vor dass sich mit einem
Empfänger im Boden Ihres Fahrzeugs
verbindet
diese Technologie BMW nutzt sie bereits
für seine 530i-modelle
man kann nicht über Elektrofahrzeuge
sprechen ohne dabei das Thema autonomes
fahren zu erwähnen theoretisch könnte
ihr Auto über eine Software verfügen die
auf Knopfdruck aktiviert werden kann
sogenannte avis gibt es nicht nur bei
Elektroautos aber wenn Autohersteller
über die Zukunft sprechen liegt dieser
Aspekt auf der Hand
nennen wir unseren Computer Jane Stufe 1
sie und Jane lenken und Beschleunigen
gemeinsam Stufe 2 Jane lenkt und
beschleunigt und bremst man achtet
selbst aber noch auf den Straßenverkehr
Stufe 3 Jane überwacht auch die Fahrzeug
Umgebung sie müssen aber bereit sein das
Auto zu kontrollieren Stufe 4 Jane fährt
komplett autonomen kein Eingreifen mehr
nötig
und Stufe 5 bedeutet Jane macht alles
sie sind nicht einmal im Auto damit
können 94% der durch menschliches
Versagen verursachten Unfälle vermieden
werden
Stufe 4 könnte bei Privatfahrzeugen bis
Mitte der 2020er Jahre eingeführt werden
tesla hat bereits rund 3 Milliarden
Meilen autonom zurückgelegt doch das ist
sehr kostspielig Investoren haben in den
letzten 9 Jahren bereits 14 Milliarden
Dollar ausgegeben wobei die meisten eine
Markteinführung 2022 anstreben
nicht gut sind phantombremsung und das
nicht anhalten bei Gefahr gut sind
Ausweichmanöver die Notbremsung und die
fahrerwarnungen
Toyota investierte viel in die
lv-technologie etwa 3 Milliarden Dollar
für Sensoren Entwickler und
Dienstleistungen BMW Daimler und VW
investierten 2015 ca 3 Milliarden
US-Dollar der größte LV Deal aller
Zeiten General Motors ist ebenfalls
unter den Top 5 das lw-unternehmen hat
jetzt eine Bewertung von 19 Milliarden
Dollar
Volkswagen investiert der 2,6 Milliarden
Dollar in force autonome Unternehmen
Argo ai Ford kaufte Argo 2017 für eine
Milliarde Dollar und wird bis 2023 noch
einmal viermal so viel investieren
[Musik]
wir müssen uns tragen wie sich
Carsharing auf dem gesamten
Verkehrsmarkt auswirken wird
die Welt der Isis und Elvis
überschneidet sich beim Thema Mobilität
sie können mit einem uber oder mit einem
autonom fahrenden Auto zur Arbeit fahren
der US-Markt für Carsharing soll bereits
150 Milliarden Dollar umfassen und
autonome Taxis könnten weitere
Milliarden einbringen Blumberg geht
davon aus dass mobilitätsdienste bis
2040 19% der insgesamt mit dem PKW
zurückgelegten Kilometer ausmachen
werden
nur row ein kalifornisches Start-up will
leichte Autos bauen die Lebensmittel
oder Mahlzeiten nach Hause liefern
bereits nächstes Jahr will nur Roll
Lebensmittel von croga und Dominos in
Houston ausliefern viele sind der
Meinung dass jedes Elektroauto das nicht
über eine eigene lg-plattform verfügt
bei der Entwicklung ins Hintertreffen
geraten wird sie werden mit Kosten
Nachteilen und mangelnder Begeisterung
der VerbraucherInnen zu kämpfen haben
nur scheint man sich uneinig zu sein
wann es soweit sein wird
der nächste Schritt nach ivies und Evis
sind fliegende Autos uber und Hyundai
haben sich zusammengetan um ein
fliegendes Taxi zu entwickeln das Taxi
soll senkrecht starten und landen Platz
für vier Passagiere inklusive Besatzung
besitzen es soll bis zu 200 Meilen pro
Stunde fliegen und mit einer Reichweite
von 60 Meilen voll elektrisch betrieben
werden Boeing Airbus Daimler Toyota und
Porsche investieren ebenfalls in diesen
Sektor der Markt von lufttaxis könnte
bis Ende des nächsten Jahrzehnts 5
Milliarden pro Jahr betragen
[Musik]
Experten sind sich einig das Auto der
Zukunft wird in ein größeres Netzwerk
aus
verkehrsinfrastrukturelementen
integriert sein im Preis der Jahreskarte
für die öffentlichen Verkehrsmittel ist
vielleicht auch Carsharing integriert
oder die Leasingrate und die
garagengebühr ist im Park and Ride für
die Busfahrkarte inbegriffen
der Zugang zu Mobilität wird günstiger
ressourcenschonender und letztlich auch
bequemer neue Verkehrskonzepte klingen
nicht nur intelligent sondern auch
logisch aber vielleicht ist genau das
der Denkfehler denn das Auto ist nicht
nur praktisch sondern Prestige Objekt
auch wenn es sich beim Kauf oft um
rationale Argumente dreht ist in
Wahrheit auch eine emotionale
Entscheidung der Grund dafür wer so viel
Geld für einen Gegenstand ausgibt muss
auch eine emotionale Beziehung dazu
aufbauen das Auto ist Projektionsfläche
der Persönlichkeit es wird zu einem
Avatar für seinen Besitzer
man muss das Auto in seiner gesamten
Irrationalität verstehen Autonomie
Bestreben macht Selbstdarstellung oder
auch Abkapselung von der Außenwelt
gelten als treibende Faktoren für die
Lust am Autofahren
wie wird die Zukunft der Mobilität
aussehen welche Entwicklungen werden
Wirtschaft und Gesellschaft beeinflussen
unsere Mobilität beschreibt die
Entstehung einer mobilen Weltkultur
deren Veränderung wird durch neue
Produkte und Services bestimmt aber auch
die zukünftige Nutzung von
Verkehrsmitteln es liegt also in den
Händen aller Verkehrsteilnehmenden nicht
nur in denen der autofahrenden
[Musik]